we begin with breaking news out of
geneva the un human rights council has
just voted to launch an international
investigation
into violations during the 11-day
conflict between
israel and hamas in gaza human rights
chief michelle bachelet earlier said
israel's air strikes in densely
populated areas
could amount to war crimes let's speak
to kristin salumi who's at the united
nations for us so kristin take us
through how the approval
of this investigation came together in
the human rights council
well this special session of the human
rights council was called after
an unprecedented some have been saying
level
of international scrutiny and pressure
for action
in the wake of the most recent violence
in israel
uh during that session we did hear from
the human rights chief michelle bachelet
who called for an investigation saying
that
israel and hamas are both possibly
guilty of war crimes for indiscriminate
bombing in the case
of israel the indiscriminate and
disproportionate attack on civilians
would be an issue of concern she said
hamas's
indiscriminate rocket fire was also a
clear violation of rules of war
and so we had different uh speakers and
countries making the case israel
insisting that it was reacting as any
country would in self-defense to
indiscriminate attacks
but the council went ahead and voted and
with 24 states in favor nine against
and 14 abstentions to
launch this further investigation and
while
uh it has no power this body to punish
those that they find guilty it does mark
an unprecedented level of scrutiny for
israel in a situation uh
that it has found itself in in the past
the united states perhaps the united the
israel's greatest ally in the region
and in the united nations decried this
latest vote and said it seriously
regrets the decision by the human rights
council to move forward
um again no punishment or
uh outcome from a a guilty finding
would be possible from the council and
certainly nothing at the united nations
without the support of the united states
which is a veto wielding member of the
security council but
certainly a sign of the international
community's frustration and concern
at the cycle of violence in the region
all right thanks so much kristin salumi
let's talk now to yumna assad live in
gaza
maybe i can ask you i know you're
standing behind the rubble of that uh
press building the al jazeera building
and jalaptail but murray can start with
this latest line of approval
of this investigation any reaction out
of the people of gaza
yes indeed sammy i mean uh the people of
gaza
for sure have been calling out uh for
the international community to hold
israel accountable for the crimes that
it has committed here in the gaza strip
in in in considering the targeting of
civilians and densely populated area and
residential buildings
and also uh in in in a
commemoration ceremony that was just
held here
at this same location for journalists
with incorporation with human rights
centers
they called out the international
community to hold also israel
accountable
for targeting the media voices and media
offices in the gaza strip
so basically uh um what the people are
demanding is that israel is held
accountable
for its crimes against civilians in the
gaza strip
and for uh the blockade that it
has been imposing for more than 14 years
now on the gaza strip
so uh basically uh the people want the
international community to take
action and not just condemn uh
the israeli uh crimes as they call them
towards the civilians and towards the
gaza strip
all right thanks for that update jimna
say it
washington's relationship with ethiopia
its most important ally in the horn of
africa
is under strain it's now under the
spotlight on capitol hill
the senate foreign relations committee
held a hearing on the conflict in tigre
and america's response assistant
secretary of state for african affairs
and a usaid official gave testimonies
in western tigre security forces
belonging to the amhara regional
government are forcing
ethnic degradings from their homes in
what secretary blinken has described as
acts of ethnic cleansing
the eritrean defense force is
undertaking a campaign of unremitting
violence and destruction that amounts to
the collective punishment
of the people of tigre the violence
abuses
and atrocities are unacceptable they
must
stop now we've also heard devastating
reports of abuse by armed actors across
tigre
the reports not only speak to widespread
incidents of rape
and other gender-based violence have
systematic attempts to dismantle society
and destroy families some perpetrators
are targeting the wives of priests
abusing women in front of their families
or using a level of violence so brutal
that women are left with organ damage
the severity of abuse is among the
absolute worst i have seen in my nearly
two decades of humanitarian work
let's join alan fisher now he comes to
us from from capitol hill and then take
us
through some of those strong warnings we
we heard about
more action to come possibly
laid out in pretty strong terms there
and you have to remember that ethiopia
is regarded
as a very firm ally of the united states
in the horn of africa certainly over the
last few months
relationships have begun to deteriorate
joe biden in the last 24 hours
has called for an immediate ceasefire
anthony blinken the secretary of state
has said what is happening in degree
amounts to ethnic cleansing
but at the hearing that just ended less
than an hour ago
the state department wasn't quite ready
to go as far and say that war crimes
were being committed
into grey they say that that is a legal
definition that has to be met
with a number of things that have to
essentially boxes being ticked
and that the state department will make
that decision through anthony blinken
in the next week or so so that is one
thing that the us
can hold over ethiopia at the moment
then there is also the potential
of further economic sanctions and that
seems to be very much
where the u.s foreign relations
committee is heading as well as the
administration
there is a warning to ethiopia look if
you do not stop this
we are going to take economic sanctions
because we believe
that you are undermining the economic
viability of the horn of africa area
but not only that you're impacting in
the stability of the area
and that is against u.s strategic
interest there's the possibility
in the view of many on the senate
foreign relations committee that
some groups they would define as
terrorists could get a foothold
in the area and that could be a problem
and then you have the whole humanitarian
issue not just
all these sexual assaults that are going
on which have been outlined
in testimony but also the warning that
ethiopia is facing perhaps
its first famine in more than 40 years
simply because
no one can plant crops because of the
fighting that's ongoing
many millions of people have been
displaced so they're moving out of their
areas
and the aid agencies simply don't have
enough food to cope we're talking about
four million people in a population of
six million people
facing what is described as food
insecurity with two million of those
being children
so you can see why something which would
normally be considered a conflict in a
far-off place away from washington
is being considered by the senate
foreign relations committee
they want to see increased sanctions
they want transparent accountability for
what they see as human rights abuses
because they say if you don't take
action against it now there is always
the possibility
this will be repeated in the future now
joe biden is sending a special envoy to
the horn of africa
back to the region next week obviously
the administration will be hoping
that the strong words here in washington
will reflect
with a change of circumstances on the
ground in ethiopia and in tigre
particular
all right good stuff there from adam
fisher at capitol hill